I gotta admit I don't usually thank you
the caller that I started this hour with
I just got frustrated I don't usually do
that I have patience with people when
they've done dumb things but I was
trying to think why I lost my patience
because in the middle of doing dumb
things and in listening that's why I
lost my patience plus I lost my patience
with his parents I want to kill both of
them they got a divorce and they were
all they're doing is pointing the
mothers pointing at the father your
daddy can take care of it the dad's
pointing back going now I'm not I'm
going to sabotage this thing and the
kids sit in the middle acting like a
freaking victim going well my mommy
didn't pay for it my daddy didn't pay
for it and so I'm going to be
responsible and I have to have $2,000 by
Friday
um you know it's just it's just
ridiculous so let me just you know why
student loan that that happens you know
what the number one problem the cause of
student loan debt is parents that suck
horrible parenting
if you parents would step up and look at
your kid and go no you don't need to
spend two hundred thousand dollars
getting a PhD in German polka history
because that's a useless freakin degree
if you parents would have a backbone and
look at your kids they wouldn't go do
this stuff they're 18 years old they're
wise in some ways otherwise they're
dumber than a rock and they need you to
love them enough to continue to parent
them just because their bodies grew up
doesn't mean that they're ready to make
all these $200,000 decisions by
themselves it's absolutely nuts they
need you to give them guidance they need
you to lead them they need you to say no
you cannot afford to go to an
out-of-state school you don't have the
money no you cannot go to that private
college you do not have the money no if
you're going to get a degree honey you
can't just study anything you want to
study and come out and say the world
you are living in oh by the way I'm a
victim of the system so you should
forgive my student loan debt you don't
have that as an option honey you're
going to have to be a grown-up and a
citizen and understand mathematics and
how it works and so you parents have to
assist in college choice you parents
have to assist in the planning I'm
sitting in the at my college that I
graduated from and I love and I'm
sitting in the orientation with my first
kid going to college I don't know she's
been out several years probably ten plus
years ago and they sit there and they
said whatever it was 57 or 62 percent of
the people that are sitting here will
actually graduate from school oh and by
the way only 27 percent of you will
graduate in four years why you can't
read the catalog you can't figure out
what classes you need to take to get out
of school so I wrote across my kids
orientation package right in big Sharpie
letters have a freaking plan don't be a
doofus you know I mean geez and guess
what we walk through the catalog with
them we walk through and help them
choose their career and their field of
study so that it actually has
application in the marketplace you don't
get a degree that everybody giggles when
they say it if you get a degree in
people laugh when you say it was not a
good idea to get that degree think about
it what's your degree in I mean people
come up with some of the weirdest
dumbest thing what's the marketplace
application for your field of study
darling and you need to actually think
that through and and how are you
studying for a finance degree and you
haven't even calculated how much in
finances you need to get a degree how
oxymoronic is that how is that possible
what's because your dad didn't stand
there with you and say young man this is
how it's going to work your mom didn't
stand there and go we're not you know
we're not gonna go co-signing out our
butts and you're not going to graduate
with three hundred thousand dollars of
student loan debt
instead you're going to get a job and go
to a school you can afford this is
called parenting people it's loving your
kids well this is why we have a student
loan problem parents are wusses
this is the Dave Ramsey show
you